- All right, so we have
time for just one more story
on this Martin Luther King Jr
Day, this is "What I'm Liking"
(upbeat music)
Last year I shared the
story of four teenage girls
from Pennsylvania who fought
their school's book Ban.
The District had pulled
books on race and diversity
including a children's book on Rosa Parks.
- Even with the discrimination
I faced being here
and living here for 17 years
never have I encountered
this blatant discrimination
against all people of
different orientation.
- No one thought that we would
have any impact on the world
but this experience showed us
that our voice does matter.
Like, we were the change.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah,
the teens were successful
and the band was
reversed, which is so rad.
This week the King Center
in Atlanta is recognizing
their amazing work
with a beloved community
youth influencer award.
Two of the four ladies
are back with us today.
Everybody say hi to Edah and Olivia.
(audience cheering)
Hi y'all!
- Hi.
- Hello.
- Oh my God.
So congrats Edah, on the award.
A lot has happened since
I last spoke to you.
So tell us about that.
- Yeah, so ever since the ban was reversed
it's just been a crazy
journey for all of us.
Christina, Olivia and I have now,
we are now in college.
I attend the university at Pittsburgh
since the ban was
reversed, we've just been
in this crazy loop of like,
reaching out and talking
and helping people that are
going through the same thing.
Olivia and Christina went to
talk to Congress and Christina
and I also were given the
opportunity to have a TED Talk
at the University of Pennsylvania.
So the whole journey has been so crazy
and now we are so humbled
and honored to be accepting
this award from the King Center.
(audience cheering)
- It's so incredibly cool.
Y'all are incredibly cool.
Olivia, you're also helping other students
around the country. That's right?
- Yes. There has unfortunately
only been an explosion
of book bans since we
reversed our book ban.
So they've actually been
mainly targeting LGBTQ+
youth and LGBTQ+ resources, right now.
So we have been given
the opportunity to speak
to so many different school districts.
We've been on many educational panels
and our goal is to really
help others have that format
so that they can fight back
against these book bans.
- Absolutely. Thank you so much, ladies.
(audience cheering)
I have never even gotten
to hug y'all in person
but I'm hugging you right now virtually.
I love you guys so much.
I, you just make me so
hopeful for the future.
Y'all are incredibly gifted
young ladies and just
and very inspiring and powerful.
So thank you for joining us, again.
I'm liking your post right now. Right?
(Olivia laughing)
And that's not all ladies.
Our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to a erase pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
Want to celebrate people
like you who are continuing the legacy
of Martin Luther King Jr.
So they're donating a thousand
dollars to the King Center
for Non-Violent Social
Justice on your behalf.
(Audience cheering)
Thank you ladies.
Thank you so much to
all of our guests today,
(audience cheering)
Cedric the Entertainer,
Pam Grier, Quest Love, Veda
Tunstall and Bernice King.
Let's remember on this Martin Luther Day,
to be understanding of
one another and show grace
and empathy towards each
other and have great day,
And if it's not, well try and change it.